[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
this
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
um
welcome i'm angela galvan and we are so
glad you are with us today
this evening i have two announcements
that are great ways to get connected at
the table
the first announcement is for our
welcome to the table class
starting on sunday october 11
right after the service this class is
designed for anyone that would like to
become a member at the table
or to just get in for information about
who we are
and how you can get plugged in to
register please
visit our website at the thetabletx.org
the second announcement is for our post
service drop-in that will be held
tonight
after the service we are going to share
a google meet link
that anyone can join to say hello to
other church members for a few minutes
there is no agenda beyond seeing
familiar faces
and taking a few minutes to connect at a
time when we are apart
as we transition into worship i wanted
to show a poem
written by maya angelou
i am a christian when i say
i am a christian i am not shouting i'm
living clean
i'm whispering i was lost now i'm found
and forgiven when i say
i am christian i'm i don't speak of this
with pride
i'm confessing that i stumble and need
christ to be my guide
when i say i am a christian i'm not
trying to be strong
i am professing that i am weak and need
his strength to carry on
when i say i am a christian i'm not
bragging of success
i'm admitting i have failed and need god
to clean my mess
when i say i am a christian i am not
claiming to be perfect
my flaws are far too visible but god
believes
i'm worth it when i say
i am a christian i still feel the sting
of pain
i have my share of heartaches so i call
upon his name
when i say i am a christian i am not
holier than thou
i am just a simple sinner who received
god's good grace somehow
wow um angela that was
so beautiful thank you for sharing that
poem and i am definitely going to take
some time to look that up
later and reread it because those are
beautiful and
inspiring words um i love it
as we jump into our worship time
together guys i just wanted to give
y'all a little
um synopsis of kind of what tonight is
going to be like for
our music um as you guys know we've
now been doing kind of the uh
virtual services for several months
and um it can start to feel especially
in the area of worship it can start to
feel challenging um
to worship together whenever you know we
never really get to see
the other people that we're worshiping
with and we've been trying to brainstorm
some ways
as this kind of drags on to um
collaborate and so as you'll see at the
very end of the service we've done some
video collaborating um but it's just
it's hard to find any substitute
for um that real collaboration that
happens whenever we're in each other's
presence and we're making music together
and so um what we're attempting right
now is to find some ways
to do very small um gathering worship
sets
that can be as socially distances our
technology allows us to be in safe
spaces that are more
outdoors um and so anyways
it's very uh low production right now
so what we're gonna share with you guys
tonight is just kind of our first
attempts
at um doing some collaborative socially
distanced
sets and like i said i mean keep the bar
keep the bar low as far as production
quality you'll see we did this inside of
someone's garage where we could open up
the doors and allow a lot of
fresh air in and our technology is
extremely limited
um but the joy that it brought our
hearts
um to be collaborating together in the
same space
is what i'm just praying somehow finds
its way
into your hearts as you watch these
videos um
of us attempting that together and you
know it's kind of trial and error we'll
have to keep experimenting and
um hopefully there's some technology
upgrades that we can get
and um that will allow us to keep doing
this in safe ways
but um but we just wanted to share it
with you
even as people as these first attempts
may be um
just because i'm hoping that the spirit
of what we were going for
communicates to you guys just our hearts
of
um wanting to worship together again
wanting
to um celebrate the goodness of god
and the journeys that each one of us are
on
so um yeah that's my prayer tonight that
that the joy and the fellowship
of being together would find you right
where you're at
um in your own space and that it would
fill your heart
up so um enjoy and
yeah there will be more to come in the
future so jacob's gonna go ahead and
run these videos so worship along as you
can
[Music]
oh
me
to the is
from near and far
[Music]
is
joy
jesus
[Music]
come to the table
sometimes
[Music]
you'll never a stranger
come now
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
come down
[Applause]
[Music]
the party is away
[Applause]
[Music]
as a kingdom of please
there we go gang time gang
[Music]
you're the best direction
that we waited for
[Music]
is
we will sing a new song
[Music]
is
towards the life of your loves
like springtime
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
we will
like is
[Music]
and like a garden
will go
[Music]
i will
we will sing a new song
[Music]
oh my gosh that was so great wonderful
wonderful
well grace and peace welcome to the
table
my name is brett and i'm just really
really glad that you could
all be um with us tonight so
we are in part two of our series titled
scripture
dealing with difficult texts and the
title of this specific message
is the clobber passages
um now that phrase of course refers to
the somewhat i don't know quite what to
call them maybe infamous uh six to seven
six two seven kind of passages or so
that speak to um same gender
sexuality in the bible uh
now what we're trying to do really in
this series as a whole
um is to look at some of the more kind
of thorny
um uncomfortable texts where really you
might say at best the bible seems to be
maybe morally questionable um or at
worst depending on how you interpret it
it just
looks um i mean what to call it like
real
real bad real horrible uh so for example
there are texts that seem
quite you know sexist uh there are
passages that describe god as very
violent
um texts about hell which you know we
then kind of
interpret as like eternal conscious
torment
forever pop culture reference
some of you got it um you know and and
so on
etc etc so rather than um shine away
from these
and kind of pretending they aren't there
right this is kind of the strategy of a
lot of christians is sort of like oh
well yeah there's those
um well we just don't really talk about
those um
that's just not really the ethos of the
table it's not really our culture
uh instead we you know just want to jump
in so that's kind of what this series is
about is kind of confronting them
head-on
and thinking through okay how how did
how does the the presence of these
passages in the bible
how does it impact our understanding of
scripture and
then um that was really the message last
week if you want like what is
what's brett's thoughts on scripture as
a whole and how we think of the bible
and the relationship of
like to faith and church and all that um
so kind of how we
how we relate to the bible but also how
do how do we understand
um kind of the love of christ in light
of you know these passages and such so
um of course you know someone might ask
uh particularly if they were here you
know last week um
you know like okay so so on what basis
are you doing this this re
reinterpreting re-understanding of
scripture
um and aren't you simply kind of
cherry-picking
right like oh um here's the
interpretation
that makes me feel warm and fuzzy um so
i'm gonna just say that's from god
you know or they might ask like oh um
like aren't you just kind of saying oh
well or on the more negative
sense oh that passage makes me feel
uncomfortable and squeamish
so i'm gonna say that's bad uh right so
the question could be asked well
are you simply allowing culture in what
is
currently fashionable or unfashionable
to be in the driver's seat of your life
in church and approach to the bible
uh rather than allowing god's word
right to be in the driver's seat so uh i
want to address that and let me do that
by kind of reminding us of what we
discussed um
last sunday so last sunday we we
unpacked two we'll call them bible
interpretation principles uh so that the
first
uh number one the point of scripture is
to point to
jesus so we base this on john chapter 5
verses 39
through 40 where jesus tells the
religious folks of his day
look guys you study the scriptures
diligently because you think that in
them you have eternal life
these are the very scriptures that
testify about me
yet you refuse to come to me
to have life in other words when we read
the bible
we should be asking the question how
does this particular
book how does this chapter how does this
verse
deepen my understanding of of christ
right of the story the teachings the
life the death of christ
how does it lead me toward him how do i
see
this text pointing to jesus to the
character
and love of god that i've come to know
in
jesus uh now that that
works for you know the vast majority of
of the text
uh however sometimes we'll come to a
passage like
ones in this series where we kind of
think to ourselves
uh oh yikes i don't i don't know how
that points to the love and goodness of
christ right this sort of uh
scripture biblical interpretation
principle number one is a failure
like this doesn't avoid it to jesus so
what then
right what about when scripture doesn't
at all seem to point to christ in his
kingdom of love
well that's our second so this is our
second bible interpretation principle
number two when in doubt use
a hermeneutic of love
this is slightly different language than
i used last week but it's basically the
same point
and i'm sure you're all wondering what
on earth is a hermeneutic
such a brett word i love words like this
so here's the definition of the word
hermeneutic it means
a method or theory of interpretation
the idea is basically that
we all come to a text and it's not just
the bible any any text
you know with a certain slant a an angle
a position and while we wish we could
simply
be know just objective readers of the
bible
uh you know to be human is not to be
objective um oh that's a good idea to
strive for
um but we also need to be kind of honest
we won't ever reach that we don't we
don't come to the bible as some sort of
blank slate right we come to the bible
um loaded down with ideas
information expectations of what we will
find there
uh every sermon we've ever heard every
conversation on religion we've ever had
every book we've read
song we've sung you know i mean our
whole culture
dramatically influences us right and it
all comes with us
to the text uh so you can think of it
maybe good metaphors like glasses you
know if i i should wear my glasses today
glasses they're not something so much do
you see right when you put on your
glasses you're not like you don't say
like oh
these glasses are awesome you know it's
it's the the idea is the way they they
impact how and what you see right so a
hermeneutic it's your pair of glasses
and the thing is we don't get to
we don't get to decide well i'm just not
going to wear glasses you know when it
comes to hermeneutic we're all wearing
some kind of glasses right
it's it's our way of interpreting um
and well you might say that your own way
of interpreting is not so much something
you you read right your hermeneutic is
not the thing you read
it is the guiding principles for how you
read how you interpret
okay that's a lot of words so what i'm
naming um is that to be christian
is you must read the bible
with a hermeneutic with an interpretive
principle
of love you must
um here's this is um not just you know
brett's
great idea uh this is saint augustine
um he puts it this way he says anyone
who thinks he um implied there is she
has understood the divine scriptures or
any part of them
but cannot by his understanding build up
this
double love of god and neighbor
has not succeeded in understanding them
uh now who does augustine think he is
with this crazy idea
that the whole point of the bible is to
increase
the love of god and love of neighbor in
our lives well
uh you'll probably recall there was this
guy named jesus
and he said you can sum up all the law
and the prophets basically the entire
old testament
with these two ideas
number one love the lord your god with
all your heart soul mind and strength
number two
love your neighbor as yourself and so i
think augustine is drawing a
very straightforward conclusion
from this teaching of jesus he's saying
look when i come to the bible
as a follower of christ i come
with this bias this
slant this hermeneutic love
which means and this is key if i read
the bible
and the conclusion i am drawing from it
does not lead me toward a greater and
deeper love of
god in every single person i interact
with
then rest assured no matter how many
degrees i have
no matter how close to the author's
original intent
i think i am no matter if the angel
gabriel
himself appeared and said don't worry
you've got it perfectly
i am not being led by the spirit
of god in my interpretation
i need to go back to the text and
re-read it right this is what augustine
is saying
he's saying anyone who thinks he has
understood the scriptures right he even
says
the divine scriptures or any part of
them in other words so if you think i
understand the bible as a whole
or even a particular verse and yet
it doesn't increase love of god and
neighbor he says you nope
you are you have not succeeded in
understanding them
go back to the text reread it
and so people asked me uh when we
started
this this church community a community
that as most of you know we are a gay
affirming church community
they asked me brett
wow can you be so sure how can you how
can you take this radical step
i mean honestly just feels risky
like the biblical arguments for your
position
are at best inconclusive you're going
against
thousands of years of biblical
interpretive tradition
two thousand years of church history
ah sure just it feels risky and here's
my response
so over the last decade it has become
increasingly clear to me
that the way we have read these
so-called clobber passages
has been hurting people
now you might ask what do you mean
hurting people i mean is it hurtful to
instruct people to live as the bible
teaches
uh what i mean is that our way of
reading
these texts has been pushing gay
lesbian bisexual transgender intersex
christians
into depression pushing them
to tremendous fear pushing them to hide
to a sense that they are somehow broken
to a sense that they are somehow less
valuable
than other people i mean for the last
five years
um honestly y'all i don't know i don't
know how many stories
i've heard of the negative impact that a
more traditional reading of these
passages
has had on people the ways it has hurt
and wounded even to the point
of pushing people to suicide
that that's not that's not theory that's
not like oh i heard about this one guy a
friend of a friend
like that's people in our church today
people we love
and who we know love us and love god and
christ
like these are not uniquely depraved
people like we we know
they're they're no no better no worse
than any of us
just people so coming back to augustine
when an interpretation
of roughly seven passages in the bible
uh and none of them by the way a direct
quote from jesus himself
are pushing otherwise mentally healthy
people to attempt
suicide i think it's time to seriously
rethink
how we're reading those passages i don't
that doesn't sound
too crazy uh and this is exactly what's
this is saint augustine's principle
right is the way i'm reading i'm
interpreting this passage
and encouraging others to read it that
is it creating an
atmosphere of love in in my life
in my church in my community in my
country
or is it leading to an increasing love
of god
and people are they flourishing and
thriving
i mean if so if that were the case well
then hey
sounds like reading it right but if not
and i would contend it's not uh
it's time it it that's a sign right that
we have some really hard work to do to
say
okay what are we
missing here like what what are we
overlooking
is there a different way to read this
um now you might ask uh
okay so you have this idea of you know
love her music of love
that term the love you know that can be
squishy
i mean what exactly do you mean by love
uh so when in doubt i always come back
to the fruit of the spirit
in galatians chapter 5 verses 22 and 23.
uh and it basically says like um
you know is the way i'm reading the
bible
leading to more yes and he has this long
list
yes love is the first thing but also
more joy
peace patience kindness
goodness gentleness faithfulness
and self-control in my life and others
lives
are those things increasing
because if so they're a sign of the
spirit's presence among us right they're
a sign that love is happening in our
midst
but if the results of our reading
are depression loneliness
sadness fear
self-loathing self-harming
suicide
re-read it re-read it
and this is why um honestly no one is
ever convinced to reinterpret the
biblical passages that seem to refer to
you know the lgbtq community um
until they hear the stories uh until
they meet actual gay lesbian transgender
christians and they say all right talk
talk to me tell me
what's what's what have you gone through
what's your experience
been um what kind of fear have you had
to live
with and if in you know if they're
coming from a kind of christian
background like
things like how how many prayers have
you prayed to be changed that god did
not answer
how many sessions of therapy or 12 step
addiction recovery groups
have you joined like tell me your story
and if you do that
it is transformative because you realize
okay this interpretation of scripture
these are bearing
bad fruit in people's lives
and here's what's even scarier if you
listen to enough of these
stories which as i mentioned the last
five years of my life has been
listening to a lot of these uh what you
quickly
realize is that nearly every time
the more religious the more
christian their upbringing the worst
experience they had coming out
why because their friends
their parents grandparents
their church had the bible
on their side and when you simply
read the bible for its plain meaning and
you are
not guided by a hermeneutic of love
you can bring hell to people's
lives there's a reason these are called
the clobber passages
others have called them the texts of
terror
because they here's what they don't say
and we'll get to them in just a second
but they don't say
well you know sometimes someone might be
gay and you know we're
we have different opinions you have to
agree with them but you know as a
christian as a believer
and god lover of god you should you know
love them in the lord
uh no no if you haven't read these it's
honestly it's pretty shocking um
so this is uh a good example this is
from leviticus
chapter 20 verse 13 um and fair warning
these you know these are pretty rough
um so here it is if a man
has sexual relations with a man as one
does with a woman
both of them have done what is
detestable
they are to be put to death their blood
will be on their own heads
um i mean
we know what that just said i mean it
basically like um it
if you're going to say you know that
this text you know applies to modern gay
relationships
well then that the text just called for
violence against them
right i mean it basically just said hey
you can kill them but you know don't
worry
because you know it was their fault
because they you know they were doing
detestable things
and let's and let's not you know kind of
hide behind like well but
i mean it doesn't say that they were
detestable
and you know a problem it says you know
what they were
doing was detestable and there's a big
difference between what you did is the
testable and who you
are is detestable right isn't that where
kind of
people go um you know again someone
might say
something like you know i can i can have
gay friends i just you know disagree
with gay people
dating and getting married you know
because i'm a i'm a biblical christian
you know not willing to compromise on
biblical truth
but but just let me ask you this do you
think the writer of leviticus chapter 20
verse 13
would be open to having gay friends
how about the writer of this passage
this is leviticus 18 22
you shall not lie with a male as with a
woman
it is an abomination
um that's i mean that's intense language
right it's saying this is an abomination
it's
taboo it's it's sick it's unspeakable uh
what about this is from uh
romans chapter 1 verses 26 and 27
because of this god gave them over to
shameful lusts
even their women exchanged natural
relations for unnatural ones
in the same way the men also abandoned
natural relations with women were
inflamed with lust for one another
men committed shameful acts with other
men received in themselves the due
penalty for their error
again listen like pay attention to the
language
shame shamefulness inflamed with lust
penalty they received in themselves the
due penalty for their
error i mean honestly is this really so
different from leviticus
um 20 uh do you think this
writer had gay friends do you do you
think this
this writer would you know what is the
things we do in the modern church like
let
you know let uh someone from the lgbtq
community like you can play drums but
you know you can't be in kids ministry
or
like would that writer have let folks do
that like
[Music]
no no and i think this is this is the
difficult truth
i'm i'm trying to kind of get us to face
in a way and
um and let me give you kind of a warning
here before we put these images up
uh these are our images of of westboro
baptist and so
the if you ever if you're familiar with
this um kind of
christian sect and i hesitate to call it
christian um
but that's how they would refer to
themselves
so if you have kiddos in the room or if
you're just you know kind of maybe part
of the lgbtq community you're worried
about being triggered
um it's not anything graphic in terms of
the you know like violence only it's
just the
language it uses like gay slurs and
things it's really awful
um so here's the difficult truth
uh folks like like these folks what this
is westboro baptist church
whose members are kind of you know
protesting
notice they are being
biblical
right i mean in fact sometimes i don't
think it's in these images but you can
find others online where they include
biblical quotations on their signs
right it's the passages we just read and
let's be clear
we just read them like um
it's it's not necessarily obvious that
they're taking those verses out of
context
right you might say they have the bible
on their side
right you do realize in a debate just
base based purely on just
the a plain reading of the bible uh i
mean they'd probably win
this this is what i want you to see this
is what
biblical religion unguided
by a hermeneutic of love
can look like this is where it can end
up
right and and so this is why when it
comes to these texts these clobber
passages
i honestly think we're at a real
crossroads
in the broader christian community and
the broader church
uh because as far as i can see um if if
if you're someone who wants to be
biblical then you kind of have
two options before you kind of two paths
um on the one hand you can go back
and do some historical research about
the ancient world
and you can find a way to say like oh
oh oh wait wait wait wait wait okay hold
up everyone
you know the type of same gender
sexuality back in the ancient
world that was like super different from
today
they had little to no conception of you
know sexual orientation that was for
sure true in the old testament
um you know back then it was all
conquering armies and
raping the losers and and um things like
love and maybe even temple prostitution
and
certainly exploitative rape where the
head of any roman household
could have their way with anyone in the
household male or female
so whoa what guys chap the breaks good
news
this is not an apples to apples
comparison
right so that's one path it's either
that
or we simply do a straightforward
reading of the bible
and admit well westborough essentially
has it right
i mean we might quibble like well
they're not very pc about it
but i mean if we're talking about being
biblical it's
they're on the right track right and you
might say well no they take it to
extreme i mean
do they honestly their signs weren't
actually calling for
death i mean that was limiting us 20.
maybe you could say the bible's worth
i mean so let me sort of turn this this
around
going back to the original questions
um posed to be my by post to me by my
christian brothers and sisters
uh when i started the table and they
asked you know brett how could you how
could you do this how could you start a
church like this just it just seems very
biblically
risky so here what i don't
think they kind of see is that that it's
very likely unless they're wanting to
join the westboro crowd
which i doubt i know most of them like
they don't know
they would run from that well here's the
thing then um
they've already joined me in risky
right every time you have a gay friend
you've joined me in being biblically
risky
every time someone from the lgbtq
community walks through the doors of
a church or at your home or you do your
best and you do your best to like love
them rather than ostracize and belittle
them
you have deviated from a plain reading
of the bible
and why do you do this because just to
be clear i'm not
my god i hope i'm not trying to
discourage someone from doing that
like thank god you don't just obey the
plain reading of these texts
like and and why would we do that why
would we be pushed to reinterpret
well because you and i both believe that
is what jesus would do
that's what jesus would do even if paul
or the writer of leviticus
would shake their head in shame
we think that's what jesus would do and
so this is really i think this is the
crossroads
i think biblically minded christians are
at
with the clobber passages and we haven't
looked at them all but these were the
most kind of hard-hitting ones
uh and i think really that's it like
those are two paths either we use
like historical critical studies and a
hermeneutic of love to drastically
reinterpret those passages
and effectively render them null and
void
um or we just embrace them and
end up in religious loonyville
so that might kind of leave you
wondering like well oh my gosh well what
where on earth does that leave me i mean
perhaps you're listening to this
and maybe you're you know a christian
who is sort of unclear wrestling with
the question
of um you know something like should
should
gay folks be fully included in the
church or should they be allowed to
marry
you know etc and and by the way that's
not just a question
straight people wrestle with um gay
christians
wrestle with with that too uh so
you know where does this kind of my
whole message up to this point where
does it kind of leave you what what on
earth am i driving at
um let me name what i'm not driving at
first
i'm not saying oh if
if only you have a hermeneutic of love
you'll instantly agree
with with me and my belief that we
should be fully inclusive of gay and
lesbian people in the church right
that's my belief
so but what i'm not saying that if you
agree with the hermeneutic of love idea
that's all it takes right you're with me
that's not what i'm saying
um here's here's what i'm saying
and if you don't hear anything else
tonight hear this please i have a
literally a one point sermon tonight so
let's make sure we get this one
do not use any of the so-called
clobber passages to decide
either for or against your position
that's what i'm imploring you to do
that's the point of my message tonight
um and you might well ask why well as
we've established because
either you reinterpret them that they're
like no longer really relevant to the
conversation
or you take them at face value but then
you have to confront that they sound
more like westboro baptist than jesus
which is right as we've established
that's problematic
so you might kind of wonder like well
what like where where on earth would i
or what would i base my decision
on um and i think
this is honestly where things really
actually get kind of interesting
you see for thoughtful christians
it's not about the clobber passages
it's not never was i mean let's just get
real like let's get real maybe you've
never thought you'd hear a pastor say
this but here we go
um we in the church have no problem
reinterpreting or just downright
flat out ignoring a few bible verses
when we need to
i mean for example when was the last
time you heard a pro-slavery sermon
yeah we have we have no trouble ignoring
a few verses here and there right it's
not about the clobber passages
and it never was
not among the most thoughtful and
theologically astute
instead what is it about
for anyone wrestling with these
questions here's what i think you should
be
kind of praying about you know thinking
on conversing about
studying um questions like this
what is the nature of marriage
what is sex about is procreation
essential or unessential to a sexual and
marital
relationship what does it mean to be
male or female masculine
or feminine what does it mean that we
are made in god's image as genesis talks
about
and in that the two shall become
one flesh like those bullets
that's the real conversation uh
but here's what's interesting but we i
don't mean at the table obviously this
message in many ways i'm speaking to
people both at the table but beyond
our walls um here's what's fascinating
is that we can't have that conversation
as individuals in churches can we why
not
because we don't operate with a
hermeneutic of
love because we think the bible in every
single little verse
is the foundation of our faith rather
than
christ himself because we'd rather argue
in sound bites and personal attacks
than actually you know like think
to have to think and pray love one
another enough to listen
and disagree without smacking
labels on each other
and so as as i kind of think of the
broader church like
this is kind of my hope i envision a day
where you know thousands tens of
thousands hundreds thousands of churches
could have the conversation
without the clobber passages because
honest
just speaking frankly those are crazy
they're they're i mean i kind of
envisioned like if they were
a person and you were as some sort of
church community trying to have a
conversation or even just a friend group
and you're trying to have a conversation
and imagine the person of leviticus 20
walking into the room and saying things
like that you'd be like okay i'm sorry
you need to
you need to go right or limiting safety
or
or romans 1 i mean that person like it's
shameful we just be like okay
please back back off right because we're
trying to have a thoughtful conversation
here
um and so that's kind of that's my
that's my hope and so to paraphrase
hebrews chapter 6 verse 9
i am confident that you
are meant for better things
than that then leviticus 20 and 18 in
romans 1.
that that we at the table are meant for
better
things that we will be a thoughtful
inclusive eclectic communal and
vulnerable people
and we will model a church that is
shifting a generation from reactionary
to visionary through the person and work
of jesus and we will do it while living
in a time of massive division and
polarization
but we are meant for better things
and so um you'll notice in this message
i'm kind of giving you the freedom to
have the to do the wrestling you need to
do why because i recognize
um not everyone agrees with me right
um not everyone agrees with um kind of
the leadership of the table and our and
and how we operate in this way right and
i get that as i said at the beginning of
the series um last week
i said a lot of you will disagree with
various things
and i'm i'm naming you can disagree
right this is not a church where we
operate and
sheer group think and everyone must
agree and be on the same page
like i'm opening up that space but i'm
saying man you would be wise
to leave those problematic texts behind
and shift your attention to some other
ones that are also in the bible
um that are just so much more relevant
because i think those are those are
important timely questions
but don't be distracted don't be
distracted
by the clobber passages all right
let me pray for you lord jesus um
i lift up every person hearing my voice
and
for those in the lgbtq community
god i pray peace over them
that they would no longer have to live
in fear of
these texts that um
are slightly awful that they would be
set free god those especially those who
with a religious upbringing maybe a
christian upbringing they have
maybe they've carried a lot of shame
because those kind of
voices are rumbling around and i pray
that you would set them
free that they could operate
with you at the center you christ at the
center of their bible reading
that they could operate with a
hermeneutic of love and i pray that over
all of us
god whether we're gay or not um
that you would set us free free to read
the bible
in new ways in life-giving liberating
ways thoughtful ways
and for the broader church lord
set us all free to love well
to be better than we have
we love you in the name of jesus i pray
amen
[Music]
blessed are the ones who do not
bury
all the broken pieces of their
heart
blessed are the tears of all the
[Music]
pouring like a sky a falling stars
blessed are the wounded ones
brave enough to show the lord their
scars
blessed are the hurts that are not
hidden
open to the healing touch of
god the kingdom
is yours
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this
is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
blessed are the ones who walk in
kindness
even in the face of great abuse
[Music]
gratitude
blessed are the ones who fight for
justice
longing for the coming days
bless it is the soul thirst for
[Music]
righteousness
welcoming the last the lost the least
the kingdom is yours
[Music]
hold on a little more this is not
the end hope is
in the lord keep your eyes on
him the kingdom
is yours
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this
is
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
[Music]
him
blessed are the poor in spirits
blessed are the pure in heart
[Music]
and to have the strength to love
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this
is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes
on him the kingdom
is
the kingdom is
hold on a little more this
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are in need of prayer or
support
please send the table a facebook message
or email us
on our website at thetablet
also for all of you that support the
table financially
thank you your gifts empower us to
continue this work
if you would like to support the table
please
visit us on our website at
thetabletx.org
don't forget about the welcome to the
table class next sunday
and the post service drop in happening
right now as soon as we wrap up
the google meets link can be found in
the comments
okay let me send you into your week with
this blessing from numbers
chapter 6 verses 24 through 26
the lord bless you and keep you
the lord make his face shine on you and
be gracious to you
the lord turn his face toward you and
give you peace
hope to see you back here next week